12 300 meter gelaufen sind
sie müssen doch einmal durchatmen
[Musik]
also ich meine ich sehe ja jetzt dass es
wieder bergauf geht also muskeln kann
man nicht mehr von sprechen
man ist durchsichtig geworden da ist
nichts mehr an kraft
drei schicksale von patienten die mit
dem tod gerungen haben drei geschichten
von kampf mit dem corona virus
und dem harten und steinigen weg zurück
ins leben
georg von schwarzenberg mit leichten
atemproblemen fängt es bei ihm an
danach verändert sich für den 57
jährigen unternehmer alles dann ist der
teufel einmal von der schaufel
gesprungen man hat nicht allzu viele
leben man isst gerne katze und man muss
auch ein bisschen an sich selber denken
und da gibt so gewisse punkte ich sag ja
das hätte früher mal vielleicht besser
gemacht
die atemprobleme stellen sich als
lungenentzündung heraus sein hausarzt
schickt ihn sofort ins krankenhaus
verdacht auf coop 19
am 29 märz wird georg von schwarzenberg
in die uniklinik aachen eingeliefert
die lunge massiv geschädigt alleine
atmen kann er nicht mehr
die ärzte versetzten ihn ins koma fünf
lange wochen wird er künstlich beatmet
als er wieder aufwacht fällt es ihm
schwer zu begreifen was eigentlich
passiert ist
da benötigt man da voll realisiert wofür
man eigentlich so ein apparatus hier in
lohr in der kehle stecken hat wofür so
liebe welche sich aber schnell denkt man
auch du sitzt hier an schläuchen
du liegst hier in erwartung dass mal was
trinken ganz aus essen und das ist erst
bei mir der fall
seit einer woche das ich
wasser trinke liegen nachdem und
herrschaft
seinen humor hat er schnell wieder
gefunden dabei georg von schwarzenberg
zwischenzeitlich dem tod näher als dem
leben
der krankheitsverlauf ist von anfang an
schwer und sein zustand verschlechtert
sich georg von schwarzenberg muss erst
am darm danach an der lunge operiert
werden
der körper erholt sich nur langsam von
den strapazen
doch fast noch schlimmer ist für ihn die
isolation ich habe elf wochen meine
familie nicht gesehen und dann habe ich
die für zwei tage sind und dann muss ich
wieder das sagen
für drei wochen jetzt am 26.10 werde ich
entlassen und werde dann die familie
wieder in die arme nehmen können das ist
aber dass das arbeitet arbeitet auch
sehr viel wenn man immer dieses europa
sagen muss das tut mir im herzen
[Musik]
und alle zu mir rüber
die beiden wollen zwar noch nicht so
aber ich werde jeden tag millimeter mehr
der wieder funktioniert ob das die
motoren ist dass die beine sind die
schulter dann geht es erst mal den stand
und dann gehen wir mit ganz kleinen
schritten samstag über es kommt lange
sagen aber ich muss alles wieder neu
laden mit müdigkeit fängt es an
wolfgang schäfer fühlt sich nach der
arbeit häufig schlapp er vermutet eine
art grippe
genau wie sein hausarzt auf die idee
einen corona test zu machen kommt der
nicht
dann kippt der 54 jährige plötzlich um
acht wochen liegt wolfgang schäfer im
künstlichen koma
[Musik]
so können wir schon startminuten
ich denke mal das maul stopfen können
der weg zurück in sein altes leben
mühsam die bremsen
jeden tag schuftet der industriekaufmann
jetzt in der reha alleine kann er
eigentlich nichts mehr machen
jeder schritt raubt ihm den atem höchst
leistungssport bis an die grenzen
aber eigentlich ganz gut auch minister
und langsam zurück sehr gut
100 meter gelaufen sind
sie müssen dann mal durchatmen ihr
zustand habe ich gerade bei gott sei
dank jetzt aufwärts vielen leuten die
richtig gute arbeit leisten das ist auch
ein knochenjob und motivierten patient
geht es auch nicht
und wolfgang schäfer w unbedingt wenn
die patienten hier in die reha nach bad
lippspringe kommen haben sie schon einen
weiten weg hinter sich und viel
schlimmes erlebt krankheit koma soziale
isolation und wer lange intubiert war
muss das selbstständige atmen wieder neu
lernen
erst danach wird der rest des körpers
wieder fit gemacht
dann kommen wir ins spiel wenn die
kräftigung dazu kommt die beine klar zum
laufen aber die arme genauso um sich ein
t shirt anzuziehen sich an brot zu
schmieren
das wasser zu mund zu führen da gehört
sehr viel dazu dass von der stufe so in
ordnung
ja genau angesagt auch wieder sehr
symmetrisch ja gut
[Musik]
bernfried burke kann es nicht schnell
genug gehen
er will seine fußballer waren endlich
wieder zurück haben
der 60 jährige steuerberater hatte sich
bei einem mandanten angesteckt und ergab
das virus weiter an seine familie
dass er sich jetzt wieder alleine die
schuhe anziehen kann ist für ihn etwas
ganz großes bin abgeholt wurden ins
krankenhaus gebracht zu werden und das
habe ich schon gar nicht mehr
mitbekommen
und dann will ich sie mal reanimiert
worden habe jetzt ein herzschrittmacher
und wenn jetzt hier vor drei wochen her
gekommen
[Musik]
früher war ich der medizinischen
hochschule hannover
da konnte ich nicht also ich konnte euch
die hände und ist aufgrund erheben und
sie sehen ich bin jetzt schon eine
relativ mobil also ich bin schon so froh
dass ich mir nicht mit den hintern
abwischen lassen muss das kann ich jetzt
nämlich wieder allein
noch immer braucht wernfried burke
zusätzlichen sauerstoff wenn er das bett
verlässt aber auch er kämpft mit jeder
treppenstufe
und jetzt wieder runter heruntergeladen
doch nicht nur der körper arbeitet auch
die seele
nach langer und schwerer krankheit gibt
es viel zu verarbeiten
der kopf kommt nicht zur ruhe die
gedanken kreisen tag und nacht
diese zeit wo ich im kies aber weiß ich
nur dass ich da in dieser zeit komische
alpträume gehabt haben die nicht gesetzt
haben also so eine einheit zb so habe
ich in einem gitternetz gehangen und
konnte dich raus und es war kalt und
dass das würde nicht auf und ganz laute
musik war um mich herum
also das war so ein sympathischer
alptraum und es ist ja dass das das
seltsame ist ich habe dann leute reden
hört ja so die ärztin kommt gleich also
muss ich ja irgendwas von meinem umfeld
trotzdem mitbekommen haben
darum ist eine professionelle betreuung
so wichtig jederzeit können sich die
patienten in der reha klinik an einem
psychologen wenden existenzfragen sorgen
bis hin zur todesangst
deshalb muss ich gut schaffe ich das
überhaupt komme ich jemals wieder auf
die beine komme ich nach hause muss ich
sterben
das problem beziehungsweise der grund
ist weshalb die psychologische betreuung
für so wichtig ist ist dass die leute
eigentlich aus dem intakten leben kommen
die waren vorher noch arbeiten die sind
einkaufen gegangen die war mobile und
selbständig und von einem moment auf den
anderen wachen sie in einem krankenhaus
auf können sich teils aufgrund von
körperlichen beeinträchtigungen schwäche
nicht mehr bewegen
teilweise nicht mehr sprechen haben eine
schwere phase hinter sich in der sie
albträume oder halluzinationen erlebt
haben also dinge die sie für sich nicht
einsortieren können und müssen damit
erst einmal zurechtkommen
ein großes experten team kümmert sich um
jeden einzelnen patienten um jedes
einzelne schwere schicksal und treffen
kann es noch immer
eigentlich jeden ja ich möchte hier aus
unserer erfahrung auch im rahmen unserer
intensivmedizinischen patienten eines
ganz klar stellen es trifft nicht nur
die alten patientin es trifft bei weitem
nicht nur patienten mit schwersten
vorerkrankungen
es trifft viele patienten im alter von
50 jahren aus dem blühenden leben mit
leichtesten vorerkrankung ein bisschen
bluthochdruck vielleicht ein bisschen
übergewicht aber nichts was auch nur
ansatzweise schon den sterbeprozess
eingeleitet hätte und ich kann wirklich
nur jeden bürger dieses landes warnen
diese krankheit auf die leichte schulter
zu nehmen
das virus hat diese drei hart getroffen
[Musik]
wenigstens wieder richtig mobil sein
aber ich bin ziegler und das möchte
wieder können wieder der alte zu werden
54 jahre gebraucht um so zu werden wie
ich war und jetzt möchte ich da auch
wieder hin weiter zu machen
ausatmen langsam hoch führen einatmen
mega zurück zum oberschenkel
ich werde das langsam angehen lassen
ich habe so ein bisschen etwas
schwierigen krankheitsverlauf hinter mir
und ich kann nur sagen dass ich
überglücklich bin hier in guten händen
zu sein und ja alles weitere
vorsicht mit der zeit das ist nur
langjährige geschichte ich muss auch
nach diesem therapien die zum glück von
sehr kompetenten leuten durchgeführt
wird muss ich auch zu hause noch
arbeiten um wieder ganz großer form
dazu stehen im nächsten jahr vielleicht
sie haben noch einen weiten weg vor sich
zurück ins leben